a spring Blizzard is about to strike in
the Upper Midwest bringing wintry
conditions to nearly 11 million
Americans this storm is huge storm
warnings are up from Colorado to
Minnesota this morning forecasters say
some areas will get more than a foot of
snow April snow it means more challenges
for some of the areas left under water
by the bomb cyclone last month Lonnie
Quinn chief weather caster of our New
York station wcbs-tv is tracking this
from Lonnie good morning well good
morning to you and good morning
everybody
here's deal you got a big big storm I
really believe the brunt of it the worst
bit is going to be in South Dakota and
Nebraska but that's not the only spot
this storm is so big take a look at the
wind field severe wind warnings or wind
watches extend 705 miles of the West 701
miles to the south and as this system
pushes off to the east it's gonna be
pulling in some very cold air to the
north so not necessarily a rain maker
big snow as well I think the biggest
snow totals are going to be felt in this
area shaded in pink around Watertown
South Dakota you're looking at maybe a
foot and a half of snow for Nebraska you
slice the hat the state in half because
on the western half it's big snow but on
the eastern half we're talking severe
thunderstorms and look at this this
areas south of Omaha and Kearney this
area shaded in orange could get tennis
ball-sized hail
I think you mention what that does to
property in your cars and then the
temperatures plummet Kansas City today
maxes out you ready for this 81 degrees
you get to Friday morning it's 34
degrees then of course it's all pushed
to the east Anthony and come you know
the weekend you got the Masters and this
is gonna it's gonna cause some problems
I think that's interesting well you know
I didn't want to bring it up but it
doesn't look good you brought it up line
we heard it live TV right microphone is
working this yeah 30 no weather
tradition thank you